What's up guys, it's Amanda Cerny and welcome to t-time
This is where I play tennis with different celebrities influencers friends and family
You name it and we have a Q&A session while playing and how we play is that we have five rounds and whoever wins
Three out of the five rounds wins the whole game and there's a very special prize today I am playing with
Rice Gum
What are we doing today at mana sturdy
We are playing tennis and we have a lot to catch up on so I have some questions for you
What type of questions you'll see a lot of people ask me on Twitter. It's questions from the people and
Also, have you played tennis before?
No, honestly
I have it, but I'm really good with balls in my hand and the racquet stuff so it should be a good game
You know I'm saying, okay, let's get started. So
Rice heads or tails?
tails tails
Damn
Alright you pick who serve's  first me or you, you go first ladies first ladies
First, you know say I don't mind if I do
alright first loves living love love all
first question is
Who do you think is gonna win the fight Logan or KSI?
Oh shit, they're both athletic and I'm friends with both of them. But I really I think oh
No
I can't do this either. They do two things at once. No, I think
Ksi I might take it. You know, it's gonna be a good fight though, you know
I mean case I got the experience but Logan got the size on them
You know I'm saying so who whoever wants it more I think
uh
I
think Logan's gonna win
Well, I think KSI
Almost got it. Almost got it, you know im saying
Why did you pick tennis? What the heck?
It's such a random sport because I suck at it and i  need to learn to be better. Okay
What is one feature you don't like about yourself?
About me. Yeah one feature. Um
Look, well. I have a lot of scars, but it's not that I don't like it
Yeah, it's just like memories of me eating shit. Okay? Okay. Okay. Yeah, like the one on my knee for instance
oh, I don't like remembering that because
It was a painful fall. Uh, and I'm so clumsy
I was literally just running it like Beverly Hills and I tripped and you know, the roads are like
Gnarly gnarly and it took like a chunk out of my knee
Oh, yeah, and I was running on the trail with my leg like gushing blood . Oh
Good times
Why did you choose the name Rice Gum?
well, I was really bored and I like rice and
And I like rice and I like gum, you know originally it was like a gamer name thing
You know I'm saying and then yeah, you know just over the years. I just stuck with it. But uh
I'm glad I picked the name. Why is your name Amanda Cerny, huh? My mom
Okay
Why did you move out of the house? Oh I see that question
So I made a video but it was just come on man. No, it was just clickbait, but I didn't move
Oh, I still live with Alesia violet and you know Faze Bank Summer and all them It was just clickbait
Its YouTube you you need a good click bait on this video. Okay, you need a good one
Because I suck it yeah, I'm actually sweating. Oh my god good. We're on the first round so
Alright so this, isn't me off again. Oh
I'm asked you a question. Alright? Yeah, and it's not me asking like it's from Twitter is the answer is not me
It's from Twitter. Here we go. Have you ever kissed a girl?
Yeah
I like it
And she just scored on me man
That just you empowered me have you ever kissed a boy? Kissed a boy? Yeah
And liked it ? Well, there's this one time, but I didn't know he was a boy, I'm just kidding
Lets gooo!
Nah guys i never kissed a boy man
but theres nothing wrong with it. You know I'm saying I just personally never have oh
Well, that was out on me so she got the point man
He's an honest player Gary
That's what I do. All right, this is game point
so
Question would be
How do you like living in LA I?
i Like it, it's hot. It's real hot. I'm sweating right now
But it makes work easier like how we collaborated like it was that easy, you know sad that's true
That's why a lot of people moved out here - what's your favorite sneaker that you own?
I like bare feet because it's just so much more comfortable. What's your favorite spot to visit?
My favorite spot to visit. Yeah my bed
I really like to sleep at night and get like 8 to 12 hours of sleep every night. Damn it. I think I just won
Nooooo Nooo!
Damn it
Sorry, you have four more chances. Whoever gets the three I'm serving now. So yeah, it's about to get ugly
All right. Listen, who is the last person you texted?
I think it was Oscar the camera guy
Cause he showed up at the wrong location
Come on camera guy you can't be doing that man
All right, guys, I need a win at least one
It's my first time playing tennis though way to I stood over here here this side and then this box, okay
You ready? Yeah
Close enough
So for you know
So question for you is who's your favorite friend who's my favorite friend, huh?
yep, honestly, I think it's you Amanda because
Because you're the one that invites me to go out and play tennis if you do hit me up
I'd be in my room not being active, you know, I mean like I'm trying to get in shape so
Hello, hello flatter me and then sneak in a win what is one thing you can't live without
Water , really got no calories, man. I love it
you can only live how many days without water? not that many
Thirty off. What's your favorite color? Ah
Black you know, I mean, it's a hot day, but I still wore black
I don't care if it's attracting heat and and I'm sweating from three different angles. I love the color black
oh its in
Was it in?
It was right here
Damn. You gotta win this one
Are you currently dating anybody I
Am currently in a relationship with the money with the red. That's all I think about is money. I'm just kidding now. I'm single and
I'm just really single man and lonely man said you single hit him, but you're single. Hit me up, you know saying
Hes available
I don't know. I wasn't paying attention
Well, we'll just redo that one. We won't give a point to anybody on that
So it's no game point for me. If I get this I win this round. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Okay question. Where is the furthest place you ever?
traveled to
yo it went over, its fine I Won!
Oh
It's to know it's okay. I can still come back you can you have to win these last three rounds? I got it
Yeah, don't worry about I got it. I got it
furthest place I've traveled to yeah, I think was
Dubai oh, I went to Dubai with ball ball ball ball. Oh, thank you. Thank you. Thank you
He said, you're welcome
She said like ten times. Yeah, I went with batch one time word and it was so random
But it was it's beautiful King bash is my boy. Love King bachelor boy. Love all
Literally, how do you feel that King bash  likes me more than you?
I
Don't know how we're playing technically no, technically no darn it man. I'll give it to you though. Yes. Yes
Let's go. Do you think you're gonna live in LA for the rest of your life? Oh
I really don't think so because I
Plan on being like a hundred years old and there's no way I can be here for 80 more years. Come on
No, yeah, and there's no if the rest of my life no way I'm gonna have houses all over the world, you know
Say I'm a house. I'm have a house in Europe house in Vegas house in Hawaii
I mean so I'm gonna be all over the place goals. I like it
Can I stay in one of your houses around the world?
I mean if you I mean if that ever happens, you know, I mean a hundred percent you can have a room. Oh, come on
Dude, you been practicing man. I haven't even played
boxers or briefs
No, dude I don't wear underwear
But if if I had to pick probably brief, let's go on the ballpark
Let's go now party briefs honestly briefs
Briefs, yeah, do you have any balls? Oh
Yeah
Thats what she said
Its really bad if she says that
Balls
ID do I do
okay, like
I'm just really curious because I don't know Oh No
40 to 30
Nah but like I've been questioning this my whole entire life and no one has ever told me but like do girls fart. Oh, yeah
Oh they do. Yeah, especially
There's these one vegan burgers
Sweet them. I swear they'll be our next video. You'll be so gassy ha ha
I've been told that they don't but now I know yeah, they lied to you. I mean you you live with girls, right?
Does summer still live with you?
Well about that  Nooo
Something you know, it's either tennis or Q&A. I mean two things you can't do at the same time woman
I can't focus I can't focus
im a women i multy task
Man, it was a good game. Come here. Come here. Come here. Answer the last question and come here
give me a hug ugh, it was a good game. You're still a winner in my book just say right here
You're still a winner. I love you so much, and we haven't seen each other in so long. I
Just wanted to give you a special gift
from the bottom of my heart
Is this some jewelry like some might like a watch or something it's real nice, that's all you need
It's a real nice. So step over here
Here it is
Cuz your name is Rice and you like rice
Thank You lifetime supply of rice
love it Thank You
It's not like a commentary on ethnicity or anything because of your name, oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Um, I ate a piece early. What  why would you eat a peice? It's mine what would you eat a Piece enjoy
Thank you so much for today. Thank you. Yeah, thank you guys so much for watching. That was fun
I feel like I improved a little bit on my tennis game, maybe not so much because I was playing with rice
Yeah
For next week, let me know who you want to see on tea time with a cerny it could be rice again
So he has a chance of winning. I mean you did win. You got the rice when the gun worn in my heart
like/subscribe turn on those notifications and comments below